動画の
挨拶が
ないですはじめシャツをですなんか面白そうなオモチャ買ったんで買ってきました
こちらラジオコントロールエアーボード4 t 4 p 目この人形が凄い動くやつ
みたいですねスゴイかなんかこういうモードにモデル診断こういう普通の中その棒
みたいな感じでもなれるみたいなからいろいろ遊べるみたいでございますでこの商品の
魅力その1
ご覧ください40分の重点でん
何度5分お遊びでしまいまあって素晴らしいピョン10分の充電で声ませ
あ時40分じゃあねして号船それがいいよ10分充電して5分遊べばいい
ふざけんなディズニーのアトラクションか40分町田爆三国みたいなもんなんですけど
ただこれ考えてください40分10年で5分しか遊べないということはその5分に
どんな顔することは詰まっているか想像もできないんですよ40分待たされた空くしょ
んは面白いじゃないですか
そういうことですねこれ食べ
めちゃくちゃ面白いと思うんで繋げてみましょう40分バックですよ
ものすごい続く遊べそう選んでドライバーじゃない
ドライバーじゃないっすよ大須でどれまずない usb に挿して充電している間下す
ですおおぉ
人形です
ウイ s game 10年寝る前にちょっと今動けるんじゃね
エアコンは文や続きました
さあさあさあこの人がさあどこまで飛べるかですねその山オートが何もわかんないん
ですけどまぁ触れが関西でなくなっているでしょ
高
パーこれまで俺の先生が問われるのは難しいんです
坐骨君の画面以外でさあ画面内でそうされてもらった1やガチャで遊んでライドに首が
なくなったんですけど気にせずにいきましょーうおーー系分かりましたがいました
もう操れます
なぜドローンなメイクとったんでローンのメイクとったんでこういう相談者慣れており
ます
ああいう曲400円オープン件ああ
on air
[音楽]
どーんこのドローンと一緒ですねドラマとなるじゃねぇ
まあこれがをず想像できます音響件
疲れました持ってるさ
ana
年夏良いなこれどんどんなぜくれ操作しやすいですああ
においでー
うわぁ怖いん
[音楽]
アース外相のしやすいこれこちらです
いやー
air
わー頭に着陸食べてみましょう
ああああああ
4わー os
[音楽]
ああすごい
喋っん
あれちょっと10年して保育遊んでみましょう別のノードあるみたいなんで
オーライ開いてあげる充電が完了しましたなぜこれ首がなくてぞくださいんでも止めて
代わりにムツゴロウ瀬さんを載せましたよろしくお願いします
これで充電が max になってるんで多分さっきよりも飛ぶのではないかなとか思っ
ちゃったりしておりますでは早速飛ばしてみましょう
見ます
[音楽]
[拍手]
me
はいすごいそんでー
[音楽]
俺
愛らしい2
car
それが堂々の逃げようって言っちゃったーーーーああそういえば
どうりでうまいわけですよ
須田ことじゃ
ファンどっちのイチローん店が終わったの申します
あーを大海だ
[音楽]
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
ban
いやーお願いします
ooooooooooooooooooooo oooo
すげー
はぁっ
[拍手]
ano
それかぜ
ああああああ
ああああいう感じでまずもいろいろで中みたいそしてもう一個モードでですね合わせる
と思うみたいですがあるねそれもやってみましょう
大丈夫これこんなの大丈夫願う
わー
よねこれでムツゴロウさんでもいけますね
これこそムツゴロウさんの宮番ですむつごろさんにずっと引っかかっていただき
ましょう
完全にムツゴロウさんですねこれ完全に入ってきてですねウツボターン
そのためよう宜しくお願いします
[音楽]
はいはぁっ
住めじゃーん
ええええええええええええ
0うわぁ
[音楽]
me
car
あっはぁ